matthew mcconaughey actually had some
some pretty good
thoughts on this whole thing i can't
believe i would say because matthew
mcconaughey has said some things
recently politically that we're just a
little strange
he appears to be wanting to angle to run
for office at some point he's got this
new book out green lights
which by the way speechless was was a
little higher on the charts and green
lights really for the past few days i
don't know now where it is maybe maybe
we've fallen behind again but
and i've you know i've heard people are
enjoying that book
mcconaughey obviously has political
ambitions and he he had a really
important point on how to think about
what's going on the the riots in the
streets burning down the country the
vitriol that's largely almost
exclusively coming from the left
the politicization of every institution
that the feeling the conservatives have
lost so much power
now we're even we're arguing over
washington and lincoln and jefferson and
the star-spangled banner
mcconaughey says the country is just
going through
puberty happy birthday america
yes indeed as we celebrate our
independence
today as we celebrate our birth as a
nation a day that kick-started
a revolution to gain our sovereignty
let's admit
that this last year's trip around the
sun was also
another head scratcher um but let's also
remember that
we are babies you know as a country
we're basically going through puberty in
comparison to um
other countries timelines and we're
going to go through growing pains we are
going through growing pains this is not
an excuse to say this is just a reality
and this is good because we got to keep
learning
we got to keep maturing we got to keep
striving we got to keep climbing
we got to keep building and we got to
make sure we maintain
hope along the way as we continue to
evolve why because it's who we are
why because the alternative sucks
okay so then he goes on and it's kind of
just platitudinous nonsense about
progress and evolve man you know right
all right all right but the first part
is actually
is actually really smart mcconaughey is
saying
this is a young country and we're going
through puberty and that is
certainly true and conservatives
sometimes get a little nostalgic
okay and we cling to the past as my
friend father george rutler says
nostalgia is history after a few drinks
and as my dead friend
i think we would have been friends had i
met him i hope i meet him someday
chesterton famously says
when you when you leave a white
fence just you leave it you leave it out
in the middle of nowhere you go away
when you come back it will not be a
white fence any longer it
there will be dirt there will be bugs
there will be stuff all over it because
you don't leave it in stasis
you leave it in a torrent of change the
thing that is
is constant is change there is no such
thing as stasis in this world and so
when we pine for this time of
1776 we're pining for something that we
can never go back to none of us would
actually want to go back then no one
actually wants to live outside of his
own time
because our time has in some ways shaped
us and so we are suited
for the time that we are in uniquely
suited for this time that we're in
and we need to do something with that we
are very very young
as a country 250 years old just about
so so what is our narrative going to be
the narrative is
is not was not settled 20 years ago 50
years ago 60 years ago 100 years ago it
is still settling now
and the left understands this the left
understands the power of narrative so
they are trying to shape
what the narrative of our country is in
order to destroy the country they're
trying to say the country is essentially
evil
and everyone who made it is evil so
we've got to just knock down their
statues and clear it away so we can
refound a country along our lines
we obviously have to push back against
that but we need to offer a different
narrative
and it's not just going to say keep the
statues up yeah we want to keep the
statues up but what are we offering what
is our substantive vision
it's the point i've hammered home for
some time now
it's not enough just to argue about
procedure it's not enough just to argue
about form and to say for instance i
defend free speech in the abstract no
you've got to have something to say
you've got to recognize there will be
standards there will there will be a
narrative there will be taboos
what are they going to be what do we
think is good
are we willing to promote what we think
is good are we willing to suppress what
we think is bad
we have to that's how culture works it's
inevitable but we
so far have not really had the courage
to do it over the past 15 20 years
and if you read dumb columns like this
crt one
in the new york times then then you're
not going to have the courage to do it
ever
are we really willing to say this is
true and suppress things that are false
i hope so i think that's the only way
that we're ever going to be able to
to fight back at all i mean we've we've
uniformly
ceaselessly lost over the past 20 years
that the left for
duped us into into falling for their
trap and they're setting the narrative
hey hold up i hope you liked that clip
if you did we got a whole episode
america goes through puberty that's the
title of the episode i'm not just
stating that but i am still it is true
matthew mcconaughey made a good point
head on over ring the bell subscribe
check out the full episode
you can also get it on apple podcast
google play stitcher on the michael
knowles show podcast and you can also
order
my book which hit number one on all
books on amazon thanks to wonderful
readers like you
speechless controlling words controlling
minds i'll see you next time
[Music]